foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
I have somehow
away with everything
anything you ever did was strictly by
Design what you got it wrong
[Music]
that you're gonna build I don't need
to release
[Music]
just like we said we should you think
I'll apologize
[Music]
and I know you'll never fall but I
believe
[Music]
Wanna Know
all that you can take care
foreign
[Music]
I hope you enjoyed that flow thank you
to everybody who voted on the song for
me to use for this flow session speaking
of thank yous I have some thank yous to
put out there to the Friends of the
channel big thanks too dark monk fire
Mecca flowfests flow toys juggling
calling pyro Terra light toys spin balls
and Ultra POI for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all these amazing
companies and the work that they're
doing to support floors like yourself by
checking out the links that I've got
down in the description of this video
and special thanks to the non-business
Friends of the channel uh Layman chinsky
and Becca paconen thank you both so very
much for supporting my work my channel
and my mission also this video would not
be possible without the kind support of
all of these lovely people right here
these are my flow patrons over on
patreon they and the people who sit down
in the description help to make this
video and all the videos on this channel
possible thank you so very much for your
very very generous support and if you go
out there watching are not currently a
supporter but you'd like to become one
you can do that by heading on over to
patreon.com directs factorpoi and
signing up there you can get access to a
whole host of awesome Wars and even
better you'll be helping me out in my
mission to bring POI spinning and flow
Arts to the whole wide world so go check
that out please and thank you
finally if you dug this video and you'd
like to check out more of my flow videos
you can do that by checking out the
playlist link that I've included down in
the description of this video or up on
screen if you're watching on YouTube
also the YouTube algorithm thinks that
you might like this top video here based
upon your past viewing habits so maybe
give that a look as well thank you so
much for watching make sure to get out
and flow today and I'll see you with a
new video real soon
peace